do you think
jeffrey epstein killed himself no i
think he was
killed by that guy that that that that
guy that they put in a cell that lunatic
uh who's that big muscled guy i think he
was just he did it for money
kept his mouth shot that's money from
whom do you think
mossad mi6 cia all three
so there's a lot of pressure from a lot
of different profitable probably
probably massage cia more
i mean it seems very clear that he was
working inside of a honeypot
intelligence operation
just lane maxwell's father was an
israeli super spy
uh just lane maxwell's working for
israeli intelligence it would be odd to
think
and of course the cia knows about
everything that israeli intelligence is
doing with americans
so uh i would think that it's a very
cozy relationship with those two
intelligence agencies
and uh i think if you ran it by anyone i
think if you ran up by french
intelligence they'd go
yeah no get get him i don't think there
was any intelligence service in the
world
whose job is to protect the powerful
people that live in their countries that
was against him getting whacked
but do you think it's possible that he
is just an evil person who is after
manipulating people and also
was a profile so there's a big earth
thing so it's factual that there's a
bigger thing evil people don't get hit
those are your facts
tim dillon no there's the facts of the
case you don't get handed a 65.
show me another evil guy who was handed
a 65 million dollar
uh place by les wexner show me another
evil guy
that got that type of uh handshake deal
where he was basically
uh let off without anything after a
judge had made a
very sweetheart deal for him after he
was accused of you know molesting a 14
year old
show me another evil guy that uh doesn't
have that kind of backing that has those
type of friends those connections those
type of properties
show me you know multiple passports all
over the world
so show me a guy without anyone backing
him that's doing it
why did they you know so you think he's
just an evil guy who is doing this
for whom is his own just shits and
giggles he's just getting off on it
human nature yeah human nature huh human
nature 70 million dollar
uh limestone yeah is it human nature
and it's like i don't think it's human i
think it's i think i think they
manipulated human nature
but i think they i think they did it i
think just i think epstein was really
just a functionary and i think just lane
was kind of a pimp
and epstein was kind of a guy that you
know made the money okay and you know
hid money and things like that
and worked for a lot of powerful people
i don't believe in loan
pedophiles anymore i don't even believe
that if you're a pedophile you're like
in a group
you know what i mean
you